they get for me
you want tony's spitzy on Joe would says
he wants to spaghetti speciale what and
have you on the meatballs you Philly
Tony let's don't talk yeah well he's
talking to me street life huh oh yeah
you know I won't even eat unless I have
a table and the tablecloth and candle
and you know this is definitely because
you're
[Music]
for our boy Butch and his nice new
ladyfriend they told me they were out
with the special being a street dog
isn't so bad at all easy chair I'm free
to be whoever I want to be walk wherever
I want to walk hey hi are you two UH
twins I'm her husband pal
AHA eat whatever I want to keep he's a
child
you know what fine
[Applause]
just remember I got this the
old-fashioned way
I stole it
[Music]
snob hell there we go I got my color I
got it let me just take a little guess
here you're the center of your peoples
universe right you could say that your
family is just about perfect
don't don't please don't well lady
that's basically all over now you're
about to be replaced replace me I don't
think so lady this is Lulu
when the baby moves in the dog moves out
[Music]
help me get this thing awesome
I'm sorry it's not awkward at all
this way it's totally safe I'm not gonna
do that
keep it crazy you don't know that man
Wow what is this place
than a great big world out there
with no fence around it
[Music]
every day could be an adventure
[Music]
you
[Music]
you